the car of the future fast or economical
this week in the interview matthias
muller ceo of luxury german car maker
porsche
mr miller the porsche spider has more
than 800 horsepower who needs a car like
that
uh
the entire automobile industry faces the
central challenges of providing mobility
in ways that protect the environment and
conserve resources
and that especially applies to sports
car mobility
porsche sees itself as a sports car
maker and so we have to dedicate
ourselves to that task
and we've done that by fitting the
panamera with a plug-in
which has a sports car's high
performance on the road but has the fuel
consumption of a compact car
it's not possible to be more efficient
at the current time
your marketing says it only uses three
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers is
that realistic i imagine it would only
be that efficient if the average speed
was around 110 kilometers an hour
the three liters are calculated
according to the standard consumption
tests
those are industry guidelines they come
out at three liters
but of course the actual consumption
depends on which driving mode our
customers use
if they use the electric mode the
consumption is nil
and when they push the motor it's more
i think there are many customers who
want to own a car like that
it's also a limited edition we're only
making 918 of them
and we know from past experience that
cars like that always generate a lot of
interest and find
it costs around three times as much to
develop this car as the carrera gt
how is that good business for porsche
well i can't agree with that number but
i can't put you at ease
the question is justified because we
probably won't make a lot of money with
this car
especially in the sports car and racing
segments
so we need products that cause a stir
and we're seeing that here at the
international motor show
that energizes and promotes the brand
and
our goal is to make cars even sports
cars that are suitable for daily use and
comfortable to drive in the city
but at the other extreme cars that can
win on the racetrack
and porsha has proven that over many
decades
the 911 celebrates its 50th birthday
this year
it was presented here at the iaa in 1963
and over the past 50 years we've
perfected and modernized the model in
seven generations the reviews and
customer feedback prove us right
we've sold
fifty thousand nine elevens
many of them are still on the roads and
have even increased in value
there's a lot of talk about electro
mobility
what opportunities do you see for
porsche in this area
our answer to electro mobility is the
plug-in hybrid a combination of electric
and combustion motor
we think
between combustion engines plug-in
hybrids
and electric cars for the next five to
ten years
do you think we'll only drive electric
cars in the next 20 to 30 years
that's a form of electric power that's
currently under heavy development
we'll have to see what happens
the auto industry is investing huge
amounts of money in developing the
technology but in the end the customer
will decide what wins out
what world does the german auto industry
play worldwide with regard to
electromobility some accuse german car
makers of dragging their feet
that was probably a false statement
at the time that was being said i know
for a fact that the entire volkswagen
company was busy looking at this issue
i also know that our colleagues at bmw
also take the subject seriously
the proof is in hall 11 with
mercedes has been doing this for years
we believed we had to expand our range
and provide an alternative to combustion
engines the time is right
the products are
we're in constant communication with the
politicians
and chancellor mackel has made a pledge
supported by the association of german
car manufacturers
that by the year 2020 germany will have
a million electric cars
we have to free up funding for that in
the near future
what sort of support or framework do you
expect from politicians or even a new
government so that the auto industry can
continue to grow
speed limits and taxing company cars is
another consideration
the auto industry is one of the
cornerstones of the german economy
so of course it's important to have
suitable economic conditions
russia is developed and built in germany
how important is the made in germany
label for porsche made in germany for
porsche
for porsche is an important point for
porsche why because as a premium car
maker we also demand a premium price
especially abroad it's a big deal to be
able to say this car was developed and
manufactured in germany
it's a key
europe is an important market for
porsche but it's quite weak at the
moment
how has this affected the company
is
a third in asia and a third in the
united states
so we can offset any short-term
fluctuations
and this year we've even managed modest
growth in europe and germany
so we've done our homework and we're
making progress despite the downturn
you said sales are strong in asia but in
many asian cities cars are often
standing still more than they're being
driven
sir what will the porsche of the future
look like
but you can also ask why they buy
expensive watches jewelry clothes are an
expensive house
the same the world over
porsche isn't a brand to strut around
with it's a solid product that's
expensive but it costs what it's worth
the demands of people in asia are
exactly the same as those in america and
europe
for our customers one of the main points
is getting from a to b without being
dependent on public transport
and they're prepared to take longer to
get there
the auto industry is working to improve
things
with projects like connected cars
we're trying to
so you're caught in traffic but you can
still work in your porsche is that
correct
yes that's correct
that's an option yes that's an option
okay
one last question which car do you
personally drive
every porsche
but my favorite one is the 911 gt3
it's a really sporty car and a lot of
fun it's pure porsche
this is uh
and you go shopping with it
yes i do but rest assured i also own
bicycles
even i can go one day without my porsche
and ride my bike or walk
mr miller thanks for talking to us